the drugs we give to kids for for
puberty blockers so I'll call Purity
blockers originally are cancer drugs
used to treat prostate cancer they're
also used to chemically castrate sex
offenders and child rapists now we give
them to physically healthy kids you're
saying that we need to do that or they
will die and so one last time I'm going
to ask you what evidence do you have of
that remarkable claim
I don't think I claimed that every child
would benefit from that the evidence is
the encounters with patients who have
had these procedures done and it has
saved their I don't want to say it saved
their lives but it has made their lives
better I can't confirm whether or not
they're alive right this second but
there are children that it has helped so
what do you have to say for the happy
trans Community who has benefited from
these procedures that's my question is
that your entire question is built on a
whole stack of false premises that you
that you can't begin to even remotely
defend